depuis le xviiie siècle une chaussée
submersible relie l'île de noirmoutier
au continent
le passage du gour 4 km qui se couvre et
se découvre au gré des marées un lieu
unique depuis 1987
une course tout aussi unique s'y
déroulent
une fois par an 30 athlètes de très bon
niveau triés sur le volet si affront
ou plutôt affronte la marée montante
6 heures du matin deux semaines avant
l'événement le coefficient de la marée
est en tout point similaire aux
conditions de course
jérôme bisol pénètrent sur le passage il
a la responsabilité de donner le départ
de l'épreuve
alors ils repèrent attention le temps
est compté il faut faire l'aller-retour
rapidement on a là deux lola à 11
6h11 si on est dans les règles de l'art
donc le chrono et démarrer entre
guillemets
moi j'aime bien repéré un petit peu voit
la vitesse à laquelle elle monte ça me
permet de gérer au mieux le départ était
très important de reconnaître un petit
peu les lieux plusieurs jours la danse
l'eau monte régulièrement mes cours elle
nous attend pas
elle court la regarde à courir là elle
est bien sens propre et course et bien
sa propre course lots déjà là toujours
on s'approche l'heure il est 6 heures 6
il nous reste plus que cinq minutes
dans cinq minutes tout ce qu'on voit là
va disparaître sous les flots la loi est
déjà atteint la fleur et la route déjà
là voilà on est au point le plus bas
il est bien 6h11 elle commence à remplir
la chaussée je m'arrête 30 secondes pour
filmer là puisqu'elle va arriver très
vite et elle monte sur les pavés la
voilà elle n'attend pas et dc dc
concevoir pesos de la voiture alors à
traverser la chaussée la halle et disco
jérôme mais vite la voiture à l'abri sur
le continent parce qu'en fait le
repérage commence maintenant un bon
repérage se fait à pied jérôme revient
sur ses pas on n'attend pas pourquoi tu
cours là il court un kilomètre retourne
à la première balise l'endroit le plus
bas du gois un lieu stratégique car
cette histoire du départ de la course
c'est beaucoup moins simple que ça en a
l'air
il ne faut pas trop d'eau ni passé
d'ailleurs faut jouer avec les marées le
vent les courants nous faut juste qu'on
arrive à le suivre
il y à un piqué sur la droite et ce
teckel à et le top départ pour moi toi
tu donnes un départ car qu elle expliqué
est recouvert way cette année c'est ce
que je vais leur faire
mais quand ils vont arriver ils vont
avoir de l'eau jusqu'où là bas le
premier aura de l'autruche ou au dessus
du genou ah oui le premier oui le
premier art c'est lui qui a trois quatre
buts de retard
fribourg 10 cm de plus 6h35 donc été
coulé une vingtaine de minutes dans 5
minutes et à 6h40 le piquet sera
recouverte aux parents ligne jusqu'au
piqué mais on compte trois mètres
1 2 3 et on est sur la partie haute
tension et coquillages elle peut se
blesser
on reste en ligne pour en voir aussi on
ne se dit pas on est les bras de chaque
côté il faut absolument qu'on est les
coûts distance allez c'est parti
tu vois on ne regarde pas l'eau ça c'est
ce que les coureurs auront pour les
premiers
jérôme a trois passions dans la vie la
course à pied donc l'écoulement de l'eau
et le sel normal il n'y est pas du team
et parfois tout ça se mélange un peu
pourtant vitale et un zoo
kluba temps pareil jérôme est une
personne recherchée surtout par les
athlètes parce que personne ne connaît
le gua comme lui n'ont personne
mais comme un mirage c'est ce que
cherchait le mot le mirage voix et
brumeux un peu ça fait ça que pour la
première fois c'est ce qui m'avait un
peu effrité raté ce qu'on parte pour
tesco va ça recouvre des deux côtés ça
arrive en plus
quand on marque on est là bas on se rend
pas compte qu'ils aux tendances sur le
sur le passage
anthony guillard est un jeune athlète
vont d un athlète de très bon niveau
déjà vainqueur des foulées du gois mais
ça n'empêche pas ici on a toujours à
apprendre
alors il bien glaner quelques conseils
auprès de jérôme ils vont traverser le
bois ça on surprend quelques-uns anthony
guillard vainqueur l'édition 2011
ces centres est un petit peu et puis qui
vont vous venez avec dans l'eau n'ont
pas le temps d'attendre que la marée
monte puis on va partir dans les mêmes
conditions que dans quinze jours pour
débloquer
moyens beaucoup d'eau la technique c'est
ça le geste parfait lancé monter les
jours le geste parfait
faut faire attention laisser le bras
pour avoir toujours une distance pour
rester dans l'axé
abdullah
un désaccord
je regardais plus impossible durant le
restaurant du coin
jamais ces conditions-là de compte donc
c'est vrai que on à l'oreille interne qu
un peu perdu l'équilibré c'est pareil
parce que précaire et on n'a pas le même
le même amorti en appel avait une vidéo
les visualisations donc non sens très
perturbée dans ces conditions et on sent
vraiment c'est une bagarre d'homme à
homme qui va tu vas jouer quoi donc
non moi j'ai hâte d'y être là parce que
quand c'est un combat comme ça j'adore
il
veille de course les athlètes arrivent
ils excellent tous prenez dieudonné eric
et abraham deux burundais et rwandais
niveau olympique
sur le papier ils font partie des
meilleurs petits détails ils n'ont
jamais participé aux foulées du gois vos
premières impressions quand on voit un
site comme ça là le haut ça va oui c'est
la première fois
la première première fois jamais vu
l'eau jamais vu l'eau oui mais jamais
comme ça quoi
on n'a jamais eu d'ailleurs jamais comme
dans l'autre les photos là les petits
poteaux lent il ya des poteaux histoire
tout car outre il y avait peut-être en
tout cas route il peut y avoir des
chutes il peut y avoir des chutes si on
respecte pas est ce que j'ai dit de
rester au milieu si on s'écarte des
jalons et on passe à côté à côté c'est
creux comme ça donc avec des roches et
où il ya des rochers voilà donc faut pas
sortir de la route car est milieu voire
monter jusque là surtout quand même à ce
qu'elle continue à monter encore pendant
une heure et oui ça on n'y fait pas
attention on a les pieds dans l'eau
continue à monter pour là encore une
heure à peu près tout
genre de course le temps n'est pas au
beau
les ostréiculteurs comme jean-yves se
met en place
il assure le suivi et la sécurité chaque
athlète doit pouvoir monter sur une
plate en cas de problème
anthony lui rejoint l'île de noirmoutier
lieu du départ
l'eau commence à monter sur le continent
les spectateurs attendent
il
jérôme est au milieu à l'endroit le plus
bas du gois c'est bon savon tout
doucement la halle au monde
tranquillement un peu plus dix minutes
passées à noirmoutier anthony séchaud
la tension monte pour abraham dieudonné
eric ce sont dix minutes de gamberge
anthony pour des lunettes caméra pour
filmer sa course
elle filme aussi les inquiétudes sur la
ligne lui minutes encore 1,8
l'eau monte et jérôme ne donne pas
encore départ
alors patientons encore un pince à
vapeur le départ n'a toujours pas lieu
sur la ligne abraham essaie de
comprendre les mouvements de l'eau les
gens de fourmi pour dire oui une
partition pour le départ une minute une
minute
les gens vont se faire plaisir certain
c'est génial c'est carrément gignac sait
c'est top 5 4 3 2 1
le top départ
les trente athlètes s'élance pleine
balle pour rejoindre le continent quatre
kilomètres plus loin
anthony prend un départ prudent
il faut savoir se ménager dans cette
course on peut exploser à tout moment
on peut chuter aussi
d'ailleurs ça commence dieudonné
découvre les perversités du bois
lévis 9h13 jaeggy 19h16 y seront là
anthony accélère mais un des cas et
creuser
et les vagues cassent pile au milieu du
passage
les deux courants opposés s'ils
rencontrent toujours
à terre les proche d'anthony où l'on
trouve son père et son entraîneur
observe 5,6 à mon avis on viole
il ya beaucoup d'eau ainsi maintenant ça
va jouer quoi la non-danse 50 mais qui
court plus quoi
vous
davos
gagner là bas
regarde devant regardent en moyenne 9
ans
il
un homme a pris de l'avant ce beaucoup
d' avance
il
anthony lui remonte place après place
adversaire après adversaires
tout est encore possible
c'est un troisième ibère de noir il ya
une bonne avance c'est certain a dit
c'est bien ça va me faire jouer
maintenant
je pense que là il ya deux ans et je
vais pas le faire monter les allées
freud aller anthony bravo anthony joue
le podium
la course à une forme d'injustice
c'est difficile pour tout le monde mais
plus on est devant - en ado plus on
galère plus on en a c'est l'engrenage
lots en marche
pour abraham eric et dieudonné la course
tourne au supplice
un ghetto
ces blessés
ayez gant gauche ils sont saoulés par la
mère qui a fini par les envelopper
va sortir dehors
c'est un affront tiennent beaucoup d'eau
c'est ma 36 ans beaucoup d'eau ça ne
fait même pas félicitations 32 ans 1
voici le vainqueur antoine de wild 16
minutes pour traverser le bois une
dernière ligne droite en forme de
délivrance confirmé
anthony lui sa rage pour essayer de
finir sur le podium
eh bien non plus il a cogné un dernière
dont les arrivées s'enchaînent mais dans
l'eau il n'en reste que trois
des piquets qui leur sert de marque sont
pas loin découvert
aïoli c'est bien
et c'est bon du mérite
mais comme ça allez c'est bon français
prends pas ce voyez
alors c'est comment
c'est le baptême de
ça va allez on y va rentrer là on fait
beaucoup de fautes beaucoup poussé sur
l'arrière fois oui
faux
beaucoup poussé
ça va encore il refera le refera turfoo
a bola eric abraham et dieudonné
reviendront peut-être
ils ont mis deux fois plus de temps que
le vainqueur pour rallier le continent
mais peu importe
ce que tout le monde salue c'est leur
persévérance ils n'ont pas abandonné car
on peut bien avoir un niveau olympique
le gua lui ne s'apprivoise pas comme ça